are you ready for a 20 inch OLED
foldable MacBook Pro or maybe even
something else which I think it might
not actually be a MacBook Pro I'll
explain why in just a minute well apple
is actually starting work on this
according to a brand new leak and report
that just came out apple is making a
20.25 inch OLED display that is going to
fold yes it's gonna fold down and
according to the elect that made this
leak when you have it folded like this
just like this MacBook Pro this top
portion is going to be 15.3 inches in
terms of the display size with the
remaining portion of that 20 inch
display being down on the bottom so this
essentially puts it in between the 12.9
inch iPad Pro's display size and this 16
inch MacBook Pro that I'm using right
now now digging deeper into the actual
report which I've translated right here
this product would likely become coming
online and either 2026 or 2027 with
other products coming before that which
I'm going to get into but this leak does
say that based on the 20 inch display
size this project product is likely to
be in a form factor close to a Macbook
or a laptop but I personally think that
based on this leak in the display size
and the foldable OLED display concept I
don't think it's actually going to be a
Macbook I think it might actually be a
large foldable iPad Pro that unfolds
into having a huge kind of external
desktop style display and if you're
wondering why it might not make sense to
be an actual MacBook Pro or laptop well
there are people who commented on the
Mac Rumors Forum post and some people
like this user this bougie life said a
touchscreen just does not replace a real
keyboard for me there's a reason iPads
have keyboard attachment
can I type 110 words per minute on a
screen now I think that if it actually
is a product like this then it has to be
touch screen which in my opinion it then
has to be an iPad because there are no
MacBook Pros that are touch screen at
least yet I personally think apple is
going to try to keep them separate and
always have Max not have touch screen
support and then sell you an iPad for
the touchscreen support if you really
want it so that way they sell you two
different products now of course there
is a slight chance that Apple could
merge them where they also have a
MacBook with Mac OS with touch screen
apple pencil support everything built
into this new 20 inch OLED foldable
product but I don't think that's going
to happen especially since Apple's Greg
joswiak last year said that there are no
plans to merge the mac and the iPad but
who knows maybe they'll change their
mind someday now if you're wondering
what this product could look like in the
actual size well Max actually cut out
this piece of cardboard based on 20.25
inches diagonally which is how they
measure screen sizes and this is what we
end up with and before I explain how
this is going to work I want to show off
our sponsor extra's super slim genuine
carbon fiber wallet which features this
really cool ejection mechanism for your
cards as well as this expandable RFID
plate to fit even more cards if you need
them and it's part of their huge up to
40 off Christmas sale so check it out
using the links below now getting back
to the new 20 inch foldable OLED display
as you can see we cut this out to
include thin borders all around just
like we have on the iPad Pro and this is
20 inches diagonally this is also the
aspect ratio of the 12.9 inch iPad Pro
and that's important because if this
comes with iPad us you're going to be
able to unfold it like this set it up as
a huge 20 inch display and then of
course use an external Bluetooth
keyboard and trackpad if you want to or
you use it for gaming with a gaming
controller and that way it's easier to
have the software supported with an
existing or pre-existing aspect ratio
they can make this work very easily and
then when you want to you can fold it
over like this and you still have a
large portion display right here you
have a display here so for example you
could do something like do fine-tuned
drawing with the apple pencil on the
bottom well you have some full image
open right here so you can see kind of
the macro View and the micro view while
drawing or you could even do things like
video editing where you have the entire
kind of image or the video playing here
well you have the timeline on the bottom
where you're kind of editing with the
apple pencil or whatever with DaVinci
Resolve when you fold this down it's
going to be protected on both sides
because the the displays on the inside
and as you can see the physical size of
this is actually not that large it's
smaller than the 16 inch MacBook Pro and
if they make it super thin like the
existing iPad Pros even fold it down
it's going to be super thin thinner than
the 16 inch MacBook Pro even thinner
than the M2 MacBook Air because it's
basically an iPad Pro foldable and check
this out this is an M2 MacBook gear I'm
going to stick it on here open it up and
you can see that it's around the same
size as an unfolded M2 MacBook Air so
even though 20 inches doesn't seem that
big it could actually still be this big
depending on the aspect ratio which is
like an iPad Pro in this case so now
with that said what could this be used
for and is it going to be super Niche
because I think a product like this
might be very Niche because first of all
it's going to be very expensive likely
because it's got foldable display Tech
and it's also huge 20 inches in terms of
the overall screen design so basically
it's going to be for those people who
need touch screen they need maybe the
apple pencil they want a lot of screen
real estate or people who would want
kind of to set up a 20 inch display of
course they could have certain stands
Apple can sell you along with it to make
more money kind of prop this up have an
external keyboard or Max also thought
that maybe you could have a keyboard
case that kind of wraps around and you
can unfold a physical keyboard and have
all of this screen real estate or like
some other products out there you could
just kind of plop the keyboard over the
bottom section and use it just like a
regular kind of laptop but then maybe
with iPad OS instead so it's pretty fun
and interesting to think about out how
this product is going to look like how
it's going to sell the price point maybe
it's going to be over two thousand
dollars at the base price I'm not sure
but we still have a few years until then
so let's look at what's coming first
well launching in 2024 we have the
rumored iPad Pro with the OLED display
so that's very exciting we even have
some rumors of a larger 16 inch iPad
coming next year so that's probably an
iPad Pro they think in the fourth
quarter of
2023 but then eventually in 2024 we're
really waiting for that OLED technology
because it's going to be potentially
either hybrid OLED or dual stock OLED
where they use two OLED panels to
essentially make the brightness higher
so they can still support HDR all of
that stuff is likely coming before this
20 inch OLED foldable iPad Pro or maybe
MacBook Pro whatever it's going to be I
I don't know you guys let me know down
in the comment section what you think is
more likely and if you'd actually buy
something like this would you actually
prefer this compared to like just buying
a MacBook Pro and an iPad I don't know
you let me know thanks for watching if
you enjoyed this video click the circle
above to subscribe right there and check
out one of those two videos over there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]
thank you